[Music]
take a look at these two pieces of art
which do you think was made by an ai and
which do you think was made by a human
i'm sorry it was actually a trick
question they were both made by an ai
we like to think that creativity is the
one thing that sets us apart from
everything else
be it animal or machine we humans also
we like to think
are the only ones capable of conjuring
up something new and valuable
just by the merits of our own
imagination but recent developments in
artificial intelligence
or ai has thrown into question this
distinctly human characteristic
ai has been able to produce art write
music
and even generate poetry so in this
video
let's explore ai and the creative works
and begin to question whether creativity
really makes humans unique
this is the portrait of edmund bellamy a
painting produced by an ai
which was made by the paris collective
obvius this painting was generated by
using an algorithm
and a data set of 15 000 portraits
painted between the 14th and 20th
centuries
this portrait is what it came up with
the piece is even signed
with an algorithm used to create it okay
now i know what you're thinking it's a
bit rough around the edges
and yes i'll give you that one there but
remember a machine made this
not a sentient being capable of thought
would you like to know how much it sold
for
well is expected to make ten thousand
dollars but at auction it sold four
hundred
thirty two thousand five hundred dollars
nearly 45 times its estimate
ai has officially entered the art world
and if this painting marks the start of
a trend
ai painters will be faster selling
humans in the years to come
the ai behind these abstract ink prints
were developed by new zealand-based
artist
tom white much like the paintings from
before
they were created by using a neural
network trained to recognize
thousands of images in its database when
asked to produce an image
for example a rabbit it will attempt to
make a representation of one by using
the many thousands of images to work
from
and you'd get a painting a little like
this
other works include a chicken a killer
whale and a cello
these ink drawings are not accurate
one-to-one renderings of the original
image
but they're not intended to be they're
abstract paintings
much like the works of kandinsky picasso
and miro
the emphasis is on colour shape and line
not necessarily on realism
if you ask me the fact that a machine
incapable of thought is able to create
these kinds of abstract works
from scratch is astonishing these two
projects are just a selection of a
growing movement of ai artists there's a
fascinating website of the same name
that showcases their work and i highly
recommend giving it a look
there's artists like mario klingman
who've developed neural networks that
generate antique portraits in real time
or google's former artisan residence
songwen chung
who has built an ai that can draw
alongside her to make these fascinating
duet paintings
and finally these real-time simulations
made by rafiq anadol
conjure up imagined buildings objects
and people
based on millions of images in its
database it's a process he describes as
machine dreaming
surprisingly the world of ai and music
is a bit more established
there's a great variety of musical
compositions and songs that have not
been made by humans
take for example the luxembourg-based ai
composer
iva a program that is able to produce
soundtracks for a bunch of musical
genres
especially classical recently he wrote
his first
rock song on the edge now for rights
reasons i can only play a small sample
here it is
[Music]
iva has also gone on to co-produce two
songs
lovesick and i am ai with singer taran
southern
you can have a listen to them in the
links below as well as sources for
everything else discussed in this video
i'll also add a link to iva's own
spotify profile
where you can listen to more of its
music perhaps the reason why music is
much more easily replicated by an ai
is that music especially western music
is built up by a series of rules
regulations and guidelines harmonic
intervals are set in numbers like thirds
fifths and sevenths the duration of
notes are organized by fractions
like half notes and quarter notes and
certain musical pieces
must fit into algorithmic structures
like most pop songs have the algebraic
aapa shape admittedly
i'm simplifying a bit here but there is
a strong case to made for mathematics
underpinning music
and since maths is the language of
artificial intelligence and coding
musical compositions are something that
can be replicated by non-sentient
machines with relative ease
another creative enterprise ai has had a
go at is poetry
as with music perms often follow rules
and structures
that can be programmed into an ai or an
algorithm
for example a shakespearean sonnet
follows these strict guidelines
a shakespearean sonnet has 14 iambic
pentameter lines
divided into three quad trains and a
couplet
the rhyme scheme is usually a b a b
c d c d e f e f g g
each quatrain presents one idea the
rhymed couplet usually ties the whole
composition together
by succinctly stating the main idea
technical jargon out the way
this is all to say that poetry has some
specific rules
so let's see an example first is
shakespeare himself
let those who are in favor with their
stars of public honour and proud titles
boast
whilst i whom fortune of such triumph
bars
in looked for joy in that i honour most
this one was created by ibm was full his
light
so long upon his train he softly left
from dark
of shining plane and to the mourn
to set her on her way and all her
fellowship was passed away
now i'm not sure what either one is
actually saying in their sonnets but it
seems that not even the genius of
shakespeare
is fully safe from ai imitation but i'll
let you be the judge of that
and now for some nature haikus that i
came up with along with the help of an
online generator
dampish a forest a common strong ant
wallows watching the puppy
windy afternoon a more passionate fish
trots
because of the fly shaggy even tied
when a fallow dry deer sneers under the
best friend
okay not my best work blame on the ai
looking back at these paintings songs
and poetry developed by ai
and all begs the question are they
really the product of a creative
artificial intelligence
or is it simply the work of genius
software developers who are behind it
if you ask me i suspect the latter the
real credit for these works
is probably owed to the developers they
were the ones who constructed them
wrote the algorithms and ultimately
dictated what type of creative works the
ai would make
at best ai can replicate but not create
for example the machine that made the
portrait of edmund bellamy
is incapable of producing those abstract
paintings that tom white's ai could
simply because it's not been programmed
to each ai system
can only make one type of predetermined
painting
so the machine is not really being
creative by itself per se
but it's only a matter of time when ai
will be able to produce works
not planned by its creators works that
are new and valuable in their own right
independent of human interference or
predetermined programming
and once that happens we'll no longer be
able to say that humans are alone in
possessing creativity
the 21st century has only just begun the
fact that machines are already producing
paintings
music and poetry in the first place is a
sure sign
that the next major creative movement
non-human art
is already on its way thanks for
watching this video
subscribe to hotchalaga for more it
seems that my biblical studies videos
are really popular
so more of those are on the way i enjoy
keeping my content varied so stick
around for more
hopefully i'll give you topics that
surprise you anyway i look forward to
seeing you next time
[Music]
goodbye